all right we are at the national
conservatism conference i am sitting
with the guy who set this whole thing up
jerome harzoni who is the author of the
virtue of nationalism and really had the
idea for the national conservatism
conference in the first place
yoram you just gave your big speech i
was stuck out here doing interviews like
a sucker but i sense uh you brought some
new ideas to the table new ideas i i was
specifically talking about what you dave
can do for for for you were talking
about me uh uh-oh uh the united states
of america yeah what can i do for the
united states of america a little bit i
was talking about fusionism
and diffusionism now i don't probably
most of your audience doesn't know this
fusionism thing it's like it's like you
know inside think tank jargon lingo
what it means is that in the 1960s in
order to defeat the communists abroad
and the socialists at home
buckley created a you know what we today
call the conservative movement but the
way it was created was it was an
alliance
of basically libertarians liberal people
free market people people whose whose
basic thought is
freedom is all you need i'm exaggerating
a little but not much
and that was an alliance with
traditionalists with conservatives
people who say look
this is not going to work without god in
scripture the traditional family
the the the the inheritance which is
mostly christian of you know of the
united states american people
and that alliance that fusion the way it
fused was
it was a public liberalism meaning the
public sphere would be freedom freedom
freedom
on almost every issue
and in private people would be
traditionalists they believe in god they
they educate their kids
so
look it had something that worked for
quite some time basically it had some
big achievements it's that fusionism is
what defeated the soviet union that
fusionism is what rolled back socialism
in america and britain and elsewhere so
it was successful
but it didn't work on other fronts the
key fronts that it didn't work on was
everything having to do with
tradition
everything
first it was privatized and then it was
eliminated meaning it was you
you you take the public christianity you
say look now it's that's gonna be
private christianity that the federal
government won't be christian then the
states won't be christian then the
schools won't be christian in the end
and there's not no christianity same
thing with judaism but christianity is
the big story here in america
in the end you just don't you it's
liberalism all the way down and you're
raising kids who
all they believe in is freedom and look
freedom is a great thing you know i i
really don't want to be
you know
objecting to great american traditions
like freedom of speech you know that
it's important
but up until after world war ii our
freedoms in america and in other western
countries they were built on top of
a christian traditionalism which allowed
this to happen so now the question is
what do we do right so as i mentioned in
my opening remarks yesterday really it's
it's jordan peterson dennis prager and
you that that really turned me on this
that i thought for a long time that
freedom in and of itself that true
liberalism in and of itself would be
enough to be sustained and yet here we
are at the moment where two plus two
equals five 3.5 trillion equals zero
males are females nothing nothing is
really working
how do you think we sort of
well how do you think you take the
message that sh that changed me let's
say and get that to the masses so that
the average person that's more
libertarian-minded or totally secular or
not religious in any way maybe not even
a believer is like you know actually we
do kind of need some of that stuff well
i i look i think unfortunately or
fortunately depending on how you look at
it
america is in deep crisis
again uh rising china in 2020 we got to
you know the mass came off we got to see
what china really wants 2020 we got to
see
most
many
probably most of the the old liberal
institutions in america the liberal
media the liberal universities the
liberal business we got to see
almost all of them
collapse and and come under the thumb of
this neo-marxism
and and and this is you know it it's
shocking to see it but this is this is
what conservatives
you know have been saying for decades is
liberalism isn't enough because if all
you give people is freedom
well
then they'll do every crazy thing like
you i mean you can't like like you can't
just give them nothing but freedom from
the time that their little kids as a
value is the only value that really
matters and then expect that they're
they're not gonna so yeah so so they
they use their freedom they use their
freedom to become to to become
neo-marxists so so would you say it
would be enough then to just revert back
to what our founders wanted i mean we
have we have freedom of religion here
but they all they all did believe in in
some sort of god and god-given rights
obviously is that enough or is there a
failing in those documents
there's
there's a split among the founders
um which makes the discussion more
complicated but also more interesting
um the the the the founders
you know we have the declaration of
independence which is kind of is a
jeffersonian view life liberty and
property is what we need
and then
after 10 years of
really kind of disaster economically
militarily
you know the the
american revolution was was won by by
people who were writing checks private
people writing checks to pay to move
armies because there was no government
that could do it
and uh the the
the party that came out of that the
party that wrote the constitution so
that that's what later became the the
federalists that's washington john jay
hamilton a guy named governor morris who
was the most influential writer of the
constitution
they were much much much more
conservative they were they were
nationalists they were christian and and
and and they were not jeffersonian in
this sense of thinking all we need is
freedom
jefferson was very far in that direction
the federalist party which wrote the
constitution were much more conservative
and they certainly didn't think all you
need is freedom john adams
all of these are people who said who
said
if if we do if we do without without
traditions without the common law
without the heritage of
of england
freedom is going to destroy us right so
that's the federalist but that's the
founding that that i want to see revive
do you see any um
not disconnect or or there's something
sort of funny i suppose or odd or
curious about an orthodox jew living in
jerusalem a yamako wearing orthodox jew
who how many kids do you have nine
there's like 20 of you running around
this place right now um that you are
trying to help spearhead a movement to
revive christianity in america
seems i think someone might look at it
at face value and go what's going on
here this doesn't make sense i sense you
don't see it that way
you know like i i i kind of see it that
way look my up until
up until 2015 2016 up until brexit and
trump i mean my biography was um i i you
know my wife and i moved to israel and
and were orthodox jews we thought that
was the place to
to to make our stand and we we worked on
jews and judaism in israel that's what
we did from you know for that's what i
did for most of my adult life my wife
and i
and um
and for me personally there was a big
change
um in 2016
when um it started to look to me
like
israel was in pretty good shape compared
to america and europe that was a big
change up until then i always thought
that you know israel is on the verge of
you know
something terrible happening and it was
true for a long time suddenly israel was
in really good shape in much better
shape than than america or europe and
you know
people friends of mine from from america
started reaching out and they said look
we we we need help like you've been
talking about israeli nationalism and
israeli judaism for for decades is there
anything you can say to us
and it turns out that
people wanted me to say things i mean
look i'm an american citizen so i don't
you know i don't right i don't have some
kind of like like problem like why are
you here in america i spent a lot of
time in america but but the main thing
is that i felt that
that
american and british and european
conservatives
were turning to me and saying
we need some
we need to hear some of what what you
have to say we need to
to hear more about the bible we need to
understand
how did you survive these things how how
is it that your jews have survived
without civil war for so long there's
all these you know very interesting
interesting and innocent questions
that um that that christian friends and
jews were were americans started asking
me and i i got a call i literally got a
call from a jewish professor
in 2016 who said yoram just put
everything aside you've been doing and
write a book on nationalism for the
americans and the brits and the and the
europeans
just just tell them what you you've
learned as a jew about nationalism so so
i did that i wrote i wrote the book
which was that's that was my first book
that was not geared to jews it was a
book that was geared to the general
audience and uh and it had great
traction and the the the trump white
house was really interested it's it's
been published in so far in 10 10 10
european languages
um
so i i got drawn to
the front by friends who said you know
come on we need you and i i i i i really
felt like
well even from a narrow israeli
perspective if america is going down you
know we're in bad shape you know it's
not like we can just you know pretend
america britain you know what difference
does it make yeah so uh so the last five
six years i've i've
gone where people wanted me
and uh and
my writing and my speaking my next book
is is a book called conservatism or
rediscovery
and um
and and these are these are books which
are intended
you could you know obviously i don't
hide the fact that i'm jewish everybody
knows i mean that's actually the fact
that i'm an orthodox jew is part of what
makes people curious and want to read
what i have to say but
but i'm writing now for a general
audience and i'm i'm i'm really doing
everything i can to to shore up
you know what's left of the the the
ability of
uh america and other democracies to
resist this this new marxism and um
uh
the like i said the old fusion which is
based on public liberalism and private
you know private christianity or private
judaism
that's finished because that's what
brought us here it had good things about
it but that's what brought us to this
catastrophe
it's a reluctant conclusion for a guy
like me but it is it is the conclusion
nonetheless it is look
you and i the first time we spoke a few
years ago
um you know you you asked me you know is
there a place for a guy like me in what
you're doing and i told you
look seriously uh we need allies we need
an alliance we can't you know
we can't just like each one bunkers into
you know
the way he thinks the world should be if
it were perfect
so today in in uh in in in my speech i i
rolled out a proposal you know i still
don't know what people are going to
think about tell you the proposals
here's the proposal okay the proposal is
i said look jews are two percent of the
population in america and in you know in
most democracies like
more or less you know one two three
percent tiny tiny minority or jews
and
i i i just think the public culture used
to be christian it used to be moral
there used to be bible study there used
to be prayer in schools and and america
was stable
you know not everybody participated but
there was a christian public culture
up until world war ii and america was
was a stable country was a strong
country was able to defeat hardships
from all directions
and
and i think it was i think it was a
wrong turn i mean
well intentioned i understand the
intentions but i think a wrong turn was
taken when
uh when christianity was kicked out of
the public sphere
government schools
now all aspects of life
and
i think our alliance i mean this is my
proposal i don't know what you think but
i think our alliance is going to have to
be something like this that
i i'm a jew jews are two percent of the
u.s population
jews need to carve out they need you
know
it's it's true we
we don't accept the new testament we
don't accept jesus we have good reasons
for that
um but
we we also want the country to do well
and it's a mostly christian country and
we i don't think jews need for the
public culture to be neutral between
christians and jews and atheists
we don't need that what do we need we
need to be able to have jewish
communities to not be persecuted to not
be molested to not be forced to do
christian things but that doesn't mean
that there can't be christianity you
know let's say in the public schools as
as long as jews are exempted they're
allowed to leave the room for for
conscience or maybe they'll even be like
an alternative they'll teach judaism
like they used to do that in america so
i i don't think jews as two percent of
the population need to
to
reconstruct the country
the public life of the country so it's
not christian
and that's my proposal also for gays and
for other minorities that's my proposal
is you need to figure out like
is there a deal
where uh where yeah where private uh and
communal
uh needs
are carved out and are
allowed and legitimized and accepted you
know by everyone
um
and on the other hand the public culture
we understand it's going to be a
christian public culture then there's a
big negotiation over you know all the
details but first you know
is is that even tolerable that so that's
the question that's what i just said in
there is
i think that's the only way forward and
and the question is you know will we do
it i don't know
i look forward to building it with you
all right if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell